ich und ein sehr guter freund sind
freunde plus mit 13 etwas glaubt netz
willkommen beim neuen video ja vor circa
keine ahnung 1 woche oder zwei wochen
eine woche oder zwei wochen eine woche
vor circa einer woche kam ein video die
witzigsten körbe von mädchen an jungs
und die reaktion darauf war wirklich
krass also das video schon ganz gut bei
euch angekommen
und da wir euch gefragt habt ihr bock
auf dem zweiten teil und da haben viele
gesagt ja wir haben keinen bock und und
genau deswegen mache ich heute zweiten
teil allerdings diesmal ein bisschen
anders rum und zwar habe ich meine jungs
auf snapshot und instagram und fragt
also ich muss erst mal sagen ich bin
positiv überrascht
es kommen immer mehr jungs auf meinen
kanal also ich habe glaube ich zurzeit
so 60 prozent weiblich und 40 prozent
männlich ist schon nicht schlecht so auf
jeden fall habe ich meine männlichen
zuschauer gefragt ja schick mir nochmal
körbe die hier verteilt habt stories
oder eventuell auch irgendwelche
whatsapp chat verläufe und die reaktion
darauf war wirklich fantastisch scheiße
also als ich das generell gesagt haben
wir bestimmt 200 mädchen was geschickt
jetzt war so vielleicht zwölf jungs
dabei danke schön
ja ich habe mein bestes gegeben aber
bevor wir mit den jungs anfang wollte
ich noch mal schnell auf so ein paar
sachen eingehen die ich auch noch
zugeschickt bekommen aber ich habe ja
nichts video gesagt schickt mir einfach
wenn ihr bock habt irgendwelche körper
oder irgendwelche ab von ihrem verteiler
also körper sind so abfuhren wenn ihr
das nicht willst das wird man nicht
wissen und da mir wirklich viele mädchen
noch mal geschrieben auch viele ältere
aber auch die ein oder anderen etwas
jüngeren zum beispiel mit elf zwölf oder
dreizehn ist es heutzutage auch schon
normal ich hab da ein paar sachen
bekommen
die muss ihr euch einfach vor ließ durch
bedenke und zwar das nicht so vor paar
jahren als ich zwölf oder dreizehn zum
beispiel dass hier wer bist du habe ich
auf install gefunden anwalt fragen ob du
lust auf versaut es hasst ich bin zwölf
mann
ich bin auch erst 14 geworden ja schön
für durchsucht ihr wie ein anderer ich
bin doch erst zwölf ach ist doch nicht
so schlimm ich bin doch auch erst gerade
14 geworden
oder dass hier ich weiblich 13 ich und
ein sehr guter freund sind freunde plus
mit 13 aber mehr als klatsche und blow
job ist da nicht mit drin
ach so ich dachte schon dann gehts ja
noch ziemlich verarscht
ich komme da nicht drauf klar ach ja so
ist das heutzutage in der jugend so ja
ich will gar nicht lange drum rum laufen
dann kommen wir jetzt mal zu den körben
die von jungs ein mädchen verteilt
wurden und alex du bist auch ein junge
wir schreiben wirklich jeden tag so
viele weibliche mitmenschen
ich hab also den ein oder anderen oder
die eine oder andere anfrage die ich
bekommen habe mir angeschaut und wollte
einfach mal auf dem partner auf
antworten zum beispiel hier hat mir
jemanden schrieben payne alles klar
ich bin lisa wenn 20 und dann habe ich
mir natürlich den spaß ich nehme das und
abgeschrieben hey ich bin alex bin
hungrig dann würde ich mal sagen kommen
wir doch mal schnell zu den jungs mal
sehen was ihr drauf habt ja hier könnte
ich echt ein bisschen schmunzeln und
zwar hübsches profilbild ich habe aber
gar keins ist auch gut so
das muss mir auf jeden fall mehr gut auf
jeden fall so hier nächstes dann sehe
ich allein schon an den schrift farben
und vom layout her
das ist nicht witzig das ist lu jetzt
wisst ihr dass das opfer hat na ja auf
jeden fall ich hoffe du bist gut
versichert und wenn nicht muss zu anders
zu sehen wie du die beule aus meiner
hose kriegs moment mal ist das ein
richtiger chor das ist ja schon
eigentlich ziemlich witzig und ziemlich
lustig aber es ist ja kein korb warum
habe ich das dann rausgesucht
egal ich finde ich trotzdem gegen mir
juckt es mich heute überall kennt ihr
das euch jetzt am rücken aber ihr kommt
da nicht dran wenn laster nach oben so
wir machen weiter und zwar ja ich liebe
dich du tust du also tue ist englisch
und heißt auch wenn man es mit 2 uhr
schreibt wenn man es mit einem
ausschreibt und heißt es zum beispiel
darum erkläre ich euch das also er hat
geschrieben ich liebe dich sie schreibt
auch auch auch und dann schreibt er
packt dann schreibt sie was dann
schreibt er weiter
und als ich schon ganz witzig und wir
machen weiter hier mit rosen und rot der
löschteich mutter die [ __ ] was für
eins live nacht ich liebe dich ich liebe
mein kissen
das fand ich schlecht eigentlich so und
das war auch die einzigen vier screens
die ich von jungs bekommen habt die ich
ein bisschen witzig fand was ist los mit
euch schickt mir doch mal was vernünftig
ist also an die jungs jetzt schickt mir
bitte
geile sachen ja mir persönlich tut jetzt
natürlich auch ein bisschen leid wenn
ihr euch mehr von diesem video erhofft
habe aber ich glaube es war trotzdem
ganz unterhaltsam also leute wenn sich
gefallen hat dann lässt auf jeden fall
mein daumen nach oben da und checkt
mainz touch oder instagram ab schaute
auf jeden fall macht vorbei snapshot auf
jeden fall abchecken instagram auf jeden
fall abchecken ansonsten sehen uns
morgen um 19 uhr wieder mit einem neuen
video
morgen kommt etwas richtig krass des
probiere das morgen früh raus und ich
hoffe es klappt falls ja bin ich mal
gespannt wie es schmeckt ich wünsche
einen schönen abend und schönen nacht
eine schöne morgen mittag haut rein